- But Blake and John are,
they are terrified of you. Look at this.
- Oh.
- Yes.
- Ariana has a huge fan
base and they are fervent.
And if they show up to
vote, we're all in trouble.
- 100%. Are you scared at all?
- Now what? I'm not
afraid of her fan base.
Where are they at? Look
at me. Where's the camera?
Ariana fans, bring it on.
I'm not afraid of Ariana.
- He is so afraid of Ariana's fan base.
(audience laughs)
Thoughts? We said this when you came in.
I mean, it was apparent.
Literally the entire
audience was screaming.
We were like, "We have no
chance". Like it was amazing.
- I don't know that that's true.
- Well, I'm just saying, you have--
- I really do not think
that's true. I mean--
- But you're like, you're a huge star.
I don't know, newsflash.
- What are you talking
about, Kelly Clarkson?
- What? No, I'm just staying!
Like, it's one of those
things that you watch out.
(audience applauds)